[Music]  my name is tucker carlson i've been at  fox news for 12 years fox is dominant  because fox is different fox is serving  an audience that is not served by any  other channel but fox is mostly  different because it's authentic it's  real i came to fox having been fired for  low ratings so i had failed i was almost  40 i've been given more chances than  most people get by far  and i had blown so much more fox and  friends ahead and fox hired me and then  kept  promoting me being kind to me giving me  chances and one of the things i did  right at the beginning was resolve to  say exactly what i thought all the time  nobody has a more loyal audience than  fox welcome to tucker carlson tonight at  least once a day i think i hope we're  worthy  of the attention that we get from our  viewers and so you know i believe in  making the greatest effort that i can  while i'm doing this